do they get me hyped because you have to
be hyped
to go through all the different like
it's kind of like indiana jones or like
a big heist like to get these deals
going you have to do whatever it takes
you have to put yourself out there so
you have to have that fire in you
and the great clients light that fire in
me
what do you promise your writers i don't
like looking necessarily like
there's a template because i do think
each writer is unique
and has unique you know sense of
you know priorities for what they want
but i guess when you look at it maybe
not necessarily a promise it's what i
guess an expectation
of a manager you know is that
they need to be able to work together
and look at like material
and figure out which concepts may be
more viable
and develop them and then like take them
out to market
and you know doing these things are very
very important you know
to any writer and you know so it's not
just putting somebody in a room because
sometimes like
you know you know writer just go have a
meeting
but why is the meet why are you having
the meeting like is there is this person
specifically looking for this kind of
material like
like i i think that's also important
it's not just
oh let's just show off like here have a
meeting here because there's some
pointless meetings in hollywood i'll
tell you like there's
meetings that you'll leave with like
they'll give you a water bottle and
you're like i got a water bottle and
that was it like
if i have a meeting i want my clients to
get paid at some point
from that relationship i want to make
sure that it's the right person at the
right time
then maybe it's not now but six months
from now
i get a phone call from this producer
and says i'm absolutely looking for that
writer
you know looking for that kind of writer
that i met so there is a there needs to
be pragmatism
from the beginning of like development
of an idea
to taking it out to establishing a
network in the industry
that you're just arbitrarily doing
something but i would never just go
just write something or just meet
somebody
it needs to have a purpose so that's a
lot of my goal is
working in conjunction with a client
sometimes it means also working with an
agent like an agent
and a lawyer or a publicist like there's
different collaborators
that can get pulled into a team and each
team's unique
and for me i want to make sure that i
have a great relationship and shorthand
with all the members of the team what do
you not promise your writers
you know i never like i i never
set like a like a frame like this is
going to be this or it's or it's or it's
not going to be that like i kind of keep
it
flexible but what i could say is this
i'm a passionate person
i believe in your work i'm going to do
whatever it takes
to advance you know you know
our agendas that's just to build like
either building a viable business out of
a client
or if a client is already a business how
to maintain that business and make it
bigger
and so do they have to exclusively work
with you
you make them sign something where they
would only work with you
i i don't i don't necessarily look at it
like
exclusively so like i work with agents
all the time i love
collaborating with the right agent so
like i could have an agent
that i have a good you know already have
a good relationship with
and then they have qualities that they
bring to the table
so for me it's not proprietary over the
client
i want to get the right agent ideally
the right lawyer
and then some clients might you know
want to publish this
maybe specifically for film festivals or
one of the movies
movies get released work with the
publicist so to me
it's almost like each client is its own
unique
business that we're working together so
you know a manager an agent could have
multiple businesses
running out once it's different than
being a producer you know where you have
a movie most likely
you make the film it gets released
everyone makes their money it's done
unless it's like a franchise or
spin-offs but let's say it's just a
normal film
a client is a is going to always be
you know building new opportunities and
potentially you could take assignments
or sell something so
there's so many more variables as an
individual than it
then it's just a one-off you know movie
that gets released so
to me it's just being receptive to those
needs and seeing opportunities as they
present themselves what do you look for
in a client
i think that like the client that i want
to work with
connects my taste so i think that like
anybody in this industry just because
like if let's say a manager an agent
passes on them it doesn't mean that
they're not
amazingly talented it just means that
maybe that rep has different tastes
like my tastes are not like it's not
like math you know it's not like this
indisputable thing it's more like this
is
a fact is this person you know good or
bad it's more like
i read the script you know i watch a
movie
and then i'm passionate like it moves me
emotionally
because i do think that like you know we
live in a
like living's hard like how like just
the day to day it's just like
you get apathetic you had a hard day or
whatever and sometimes you're just like
all right
this day felt like the next day and
you're like whatever but
if you read a really good script it
stops time you're like
oh my god like i'm feeling this writer's
voice
like it it just is moving me and that's
the kind of
uh client that i want is that they move
me specifically
you know i might they might not remove
the other manager you know at this
company and that's fine
or vice versa there might be a totally
viable client that doesn't
excite me but another manager loves
working with them so it's very specific
to my curation
is going to be that do they get me hyped
because you have to be hyped
to go through all the different like
it's kind of like indiana jones or like
a big height it's like to get these
deals going you have to do whatever it
takes
you have to put yourself out there so
you have to have that fire in you
and the great clients light that fire in
me um
and now beyond that aspect of it we also
need to have like
a good back and forth like it needs to
be like hey
we're working together because we like
you know we like each other enough you
know it doesn't mean like
oh my god like this client this client
is exactly like me i'm not looking for
me
i don't care if they're different
backgrounds everything to me it's not
like i'm looking for like uh i want to
rap myself i want to write
voices that excite me because i've never
seen anything like it
that's what gets me into it so so i'm
just mean that we have a relationship
that
is really about listening to each other
and respecting each other
and open to different ideas and once you
have the
the work that makes you
get moving and get going and making
making things happen
plus you have that partnership where we
could adapt
to like we're saying the chaos of of
anything that is thrown at us
that's like the ideal client for me
when you say chaos what kind of chaos
could come up
i think that like the entertainment
industry
is unlike a lot of other fields
because how quickly it mutates there's
always
new opportunities but at the same time
there could be new risks
so which you think you know let's say
from the 90s may not work now
or what indus it's just everything's
rapidly
changing which is why you know it's also
kind of fun
because you're like who knows what's
happening next but it just means you
just have to keep your eye out there
and see what's happening and be like
tapped in
to to these innovations
and that's you know to me what the chaos
is it's like and that
bleeds into your day-to-day too so on a
macro level
there's all these shifts but it creates
ripple effects
that you feel you know immediately
and that's what you have to be okay with
you're not getting into this
business because you're like you want
something that's very like
stagnant you get into it because you
want something
that could just be super
compelling all the time because you
don't know what's going to happen next
and to me that's why i'm excited about
my work
do you like to be kept guessing
sometimes it's not that i want to be
kept guessing
is that like i've always been interested
in media and technology
like i've always been interested in
movies how they're distributed how
they're monetized
so for me i love just seeing like
i love seeing this world shifting and
seeing
new new like possibilities like so when
you see netflix and suddenly you watch
like you know a limited series that
queen's gambit on you're like wow like
that's possible like i haven't seen a
limited series like that before so like
to me it's about getting inspired like
you know i'm
very open to finding inspiration
as new projects get made and new
businesses advance
and then you could see like an
opportunity like podcasting podcasting
is starting to blow up and it's so much
fun to also manage some podcasters and
work with them and
work on those unique deals that are
starting to surface from major companies
so that's what gets me and it's the
inspiration around
these new uh new innovations
that's what gets me like you know
interested in the next
you know the next one and you had a
podcast yourself
yeah i had a podcast called hollywood
2.0 and it was basically
a podcast that covered the intersection
of media and technology
and we talked to everybody from like uh
people create virtual reality
people created distribution companies
digitally
and it was exciting to just see like
what the
you know trailblazers are doing and did
you notice i don't know what year you
started that
by the way i don't remember exactly when
i started i did it for a few years and
you know before i was a manager and it
just was
it was also fun it was like seeing it
and then seeing how other people are
experiencing
the industry and and where it's going
because the people i talked to were the
ones that are always on the
bleeding edge of innovation so somebody
could be from like the sundance
uh you know innovation you know at
sundance studying virtual reality and
innovation and
that speaker could be coming from that
point of view so to me it was fun
to um watch these businesses evolve and
some of them actually one of them got
acquired one of the
the the founders like sold a uh a
podcast company so it was really cool to
see the acquisition and see
money move into the podcast space and
that was like the early
sign of the you know signals of things
that come so yeah i really enjoyed it
in a lot of ways i keep doing it like
through my work by
seeing you know maybe a movie that i
have a client
makes could also be a tv show like how
do you spin off a film
into tv and that's starting to become
like you start seeing that people are
thinking that way like you'll see a show
um that will be starting as a movie and
like recently there was a great
film that's on netflix called the hater
and that was
uh you know sold to hbo as a tv show
pitch
so that's something that's really unique
to me i'm like wow like you could do
that
so that's why i got inspired but it's
like what if i got one of my clients
movies facility like that kind of thing
always keeps me uh keeps me thinking
you